ou est-ce que vous dormez en général la
rue la rue 38% des sdf sont des femmes
pour elle la double peine à cause de
leur condition de femme
elles sont des victimes des proies livré
à la jungle de la rue un constat fait en
1972 alors oui il est attaqué j'ai une
vente et la situation n'a pas changé en
2010 cet exemple les femmes sdf
cherchant un abri se voit proposer un
toit contre des faveurs sexuelles
pour les protéger dès les années 70 des
structures réservées exclusivement aux
femmes sont mises en place
vous entendez bien avec les personnages
comme ci comme ça c'est pas toujours
enfin je suis très philosophe ça va
quand même
aujourd'hui encore les femmes sdf sont
considérés comme publics prioritaires
pour avoir accès aux centres
d'hébergement d'après l'insee elles sont
31% être hébergés en logement associatif
contre 19% des hommes seuls mais malgré
ça l'offre n'est pas suffisante et les
femmes doivent parfois aller dans des
centres mixtes
ce centre roquet le connaît d'autant
mieux qu'elle y vient régulièrement
pourtant elles sont toujours aussi mal à
l'aise ici il n'ya que des hommes
elle préfère rester à l'écart
les logements associatif aimerait
intervenir sur du long terme plutôt que
de réagir à des situations d'urgence
exemple en 1994
ce sont des personnes qui souvent ont
galéré qui journaux des situations
difficiles et donc on ne peut raisonner
la réinsertion que dans la durée
plusieurs mois voire un an deux ans
c'est quelque chose de lourd
les demandes des femmes seules au 115
ont augmenté de 66 % entre 2006 et 2016
selon l'armée du salut
[Musique]